[Musique]
comment tu fais dégager certains il en
parlant de dégager oui un peu oublier
une promesse comme admis les faits il ya
trois-quatre jours que janine drai
je vous vois là une voie de chapeau aux
véhicules m'étais préparé je me suis
échauffé je me suis entraîné et j'ai
bossé comme un fou vous l'a dit mais les
mais si je veux animée parce que jeanne
cherhal angeles qu est-ce que vous avez
isabelle et élégantissime aujourd'hui je
préfère vous maintenant c'est toi c'est
toi de bernard bernard qui est un grand
professionnel à tello va voir s'ils
croient à jean-michel pas du tout
j'aimerais bien que les dix dernières
minutes soit animée par bernard allez
mettez vous d'accord
les dix dernières minutes ça m'a plombé
la cote gilles gobbo alors peut pas être
pire que castaldi
ça va être très très dur voyez tout de
suite un décodeur jean-michel le point
c'est ça
[Musique]